why do people frequently use flowers as
an example of natural beauty but not
plant roots biologically they serve
different functions roots absorb water
and nutrients from the soil and
stabilize the plant the flower on the
other hand is an advertisement to animal
pollinators flowers rely on the
subjective sensory perception of bees
and other pollinators who see the flower
evaluate that experience and then decide
whether to feed on its nectar the
reproductive success of the flower
depends on this decision and if it is
successful they will soon be more like
it
the optimal floral design cannot be
determined by adaptation to physical
laws but only by how often it produces a
subjective response within the
pollinator wind pollinated flowers whose
function can be described entirely by
physical forces have flowers that are
devoid of any obvious aesthetic
qualities the current discipline of
aesthetics is organized exclusively
around the experiences of human beings
beauty is treated as only a human
perception it is popular opinion that
the beautiful colors seen in birds are
of practical origin showing any
potential mates that the individual is
healthy but if you look at all the crazy
displays it seems to me that there are
perhaps more practical ways to convey
this information the bird displays and
the flowers still rely on a subjective
perception within the brain of an animal
that can't just be explained by
practicalities
art is a form of communication that
evolves and is defined by the way it is
perceived over time the bees make
flowers more artistic through selection
the disciplines of aesthetics art
criticism and art history should really
encompass both humans and nonhumans and
should include evolutionary and
behavioral biology in the history of
cosmology each step humans have taken
away from being the center of the
universe has produced an expansion in
our knowledge of reality
removing humans as the pillar of art and
beauty will be a step towards a greater
understanding of the beauty in the world
around us